all right glad you are with us as we get
you set for week 17 we will not talk
about the jets in new england
not going to talk about vegas denver
we're not going to talk about the
chargers in kansas city
minnesota detroit those are the only
four games that don't matter
the good news is we've got a dozen games
on the last sunday of the season
that matters so we'll be busy football
night's going to be uh
it's going to be a three-ring circus
getting the show on the air but we'll
have a lot of fun of course rodney tony
and mike florio and mike tarico with you
here now mike florio i'm gonna i'm gonna
start with you
and i want to start with pittsburgh and
that news that they're gonna respect
roethlisberger
here in week 17 against cleveland when
they could become a two seed
the sign is we'd rather be healthy as
opposed to be the three
to be the two seed and may cost them a
home playoff game in the second round
your thoughts on the reaction from
pittsburgh and that announcement from
mike tomlin
well you know this is a calculated
decision that mike tomlin had to make
over what you prioritize and when you
consider everything his team has been
through this year from the standpoint of
the bye week that that was postponed or
not postponed but actually canceled
because they got ready for the titans
week four
then they didn't play the titans week
four then their bi-week week
seven became the titans game and then
with the thanksgiving game they got
moved six days
they haven't really had a break and when
you throw on top of it the conflicting
information about whether and to what
extent ben roethlisberger has a knee
injury
at a minimum it makes sense to give him
a break
understanding that yeah if we get to the
divisional round
we may have to go to buffalo but if we
don't give some of these guys a break
we may not get to the divisional round
and i think that's the analysis mike
tomlin
engaged in and look there's still a
chance i guess that they could beat the
browns
without ben roethlisberger uh not a
great chance but but i i respect what
tomlin's doing because he's got some
guys who desperately need
a bit of a break going into the
postseason
yeah and you hit it mike calculation and
i i know that's what mike tomlin is
sitting there doing
hey we can go all out it would be great
to be the number two seed
but is miami really going to be able to
go
in the cold and beat buffalo if they
don't do that
then it doesn't matter to us so why take
that risk why not get ourselves ready
if by some chance miami beats buffalo we
missed out on it we've just got to win
on the road instead of at home two weeks
from now
yeah guys i think this is a smart move
by mike tomlin any
any time you get an opportunity to rest
your players
and allow them to just get that recovery
it's huge especially an old quarterback
i mean you look
on a defensive side they've had some
injuries and it's nothing like
you can ask coach dungey it's nothing
like being able to get that extra week's
rest off
and it just rejuvenates it just
refreshes everyone mike
i just hear you two guys have
experienced it so often right i'll come
right back to you on the buffalo part of
this equation they look so good monday
in new england bills fans that game
could have lasted eight hours
because it was 20 years of watching the
patriots beat up on them
they seem to be enjoying that moment do
you see rodney a team
over the last couple of weeks on
national tv that's getting comfortable
with everybody
knowing they're a pretty good team and
maybe they're more ready for the playoff
stage now than they were the last couple
of years
yeah very comfortable mike and actually
embracing
just all the success but doing it in a
very humble way you saw
um just the way stefan diggs and josh
allen and just how everyone talks about
each other and no one really
says hey it's all me they're always
deflecting attention off to their their
teammates so i like what buffalo's doing
i thought the defense has been a lot
more aggressive leslie frazier's done a
really wonderful job and no one's really
talking about leslie frazier
the job that he's done the last month of
the season coach
you're right and they've had to really
uh recover on defense and replace some
people
and they've done it and their defense is
playing much better
than they were at the beginning of the
year and to me that's going to be the
key they're going to score points
and can they stop people in the critical
times and they're showing more signs of
that so
they're very dangerous in my opinion
and i think for that reason they need to
keep the pedal to the metal you know
there's
an unknown at this point what the bills
are going to do this weekend and
i i kind of think that that both the
bills and the steelers aren't thrilled
about the prospect of being the two seed
if it means facing baltimore right out
of the gates
but i like the idea of the bills
continuing to push
and push and push since the bye week
since the hail murray game
they have become a different team
they've now won five in a row
all by double digits they've been
dominant the last two games
and i think that convincing themselves
that they're dominant
convincing their opponents that they're
dominant i think that's the key
to having success in january especially
if they cross
paths with the chiefs i just see this
one thing
good good roger no i just say this is a
team that really doesn't lack confidence
if you have an opportunity to get that
week off i mean they've been grinding i
mean
not just physically or just mentally but
dealing with the whole covet thing so
anytime
you get an opportunity to let those guys
rest especially
seeing jordan poyer um basically get
carried off the field on monday
matt milano had some issues you know
he's come back he's healthy
if you can give those defensive players
that have played so hard and so tough
and some of those offensive alignment if
you can give them
an opportunity to rest before you go
into the playoffs
and that rest that one week feels like
an eternity
when you've gone through everything that
these guys have gone through
from all the testing from all the
different challenges them not being able
to spend time with their their families
and so many of them sacrificing so much
i think you just have to give
give them a break mike and just say you
know what whoever is the number two seed
whoever we play we just have to line up
and play
it's a good point mike you bring that up
as well does buffalo keep the pedal down
or
do they rest guys cole beasley hurt he's
weak to weak
tony there are a whole bunch of
scenarios this whole color-coded chart
these are all the scenarios for who
could be the seven seed right
so you're not going to know until the
game is going on what's gonna happen
tony would you have and we have the
games played simultaneously which is a
lot of fun
would you have somebody in the box
letting you know as the head coach
hey coach pittsburgh is down big and
they're just running the ball
so it looks like they're laying down if
you were sean mcdermott would you want
that
information in game you you do
want that information but you don't want
your players to get it
and you don't want them to have it
because uh that's what you would do
hey it doesn't matter now at this point
pittsburgh
is not gonna win this game we can take
our guys out now we don't have to take
that risk at the end
uh you can make that decision on your
own but you don't want your players to
know i remember we were in tampa and we
were scoreboard watching
and i had the people take not show the
scores on the screen and
my boys were on the sideline telling the
players so they're they're losing
uh
in this day and age it happens you got
to just remind them hey
focus on what we do and you know what
coach
coach belichick used to always tell us
and he would be dead serious he says
guys
when i walk on that sideline i want
everybody
ready to play i don't want to see any
helmets any baseball hats any shoulder
pads off
you better be ready to play or you're
going to get a big fine so
yeah you're absolutely right about that
coach be ready to play
rodney did you ever scoreboard watch
during a game
i did mike i really just paid attention
to what i have to do and try to take
care of business the way we need to take
care of business everything else
will work itself out i i figured that
was going to be the answer mike floria i
just thought of this
with the whole scoreboard watching deal
it's different now it's not like you
have to put the scores up for the fans
right in many of these places not all
but many of the games that can be played
sunday there are no fans
so you really as the home coach have
great control
over the information getting or not
getting to your teams
in a situation like this yeah absolutely
and i agree with coach dungy's approach
you want to know so you can make big
picture decisions you can decide
who to take out who to put in and
ideally you don't want your players to
know but but how do they not know at a
minimum at half time you know guys are
going to be turning their phones on
in their lockers and checking the scores
of the other games and there's going to
be somebody down there whether it's
kids of the coach or whoever who knows
what's going on and they're going to be
telling the guys as the game unfolds
what what what really happened so
at that point you may as well just put
the scores up even if fans aren't there
that's my favorite story i love that
tony what about the tua
conversation with fitzpatrick in buffalo
for
in miami for the game in buffalo on
sunday do you like the decision that was
made
right out of the gate by brian flores
announcing it saturday night not letting
it fester
and this is the way we're going to go i
absolutely do and i think it's the right
decision
tuatanga vailoa has some growing to do
and there's situations where he's not
going to be at his best
ryan fitzpatrick to their
uh benefit functions well in those
situations so i would start to uh
every week you know people have to plan
for him and the things that he does
now if i fall behind or if it's
fluttering or i need that one drive
ryan has shown he can go in there and
create it right away so i think they've
got the best of all worlds
and more than anything the team is on
board and ryan fitzpatrick is on board
with that
yeah and i just believe they absolutely
trust brian flores and whatever he he
says and if you're two i mean if you're
too and you get an opportunity as a
coach to give him
that experience and see how well he does
in that playoff atmosphere that's huge
that's experience
those are reps that he gets and moving
forward like coach said
if he struggles then you could put
fitzpatrick in there
and then see what happens but i just
love the fact that this young player
this young quarterback gets to get some
of those
playoff tight caliber reps
and in this climate with so many
coaches in the mix for coach of the year
how do you not give brian flores extra
credit
for coming up with a way to make this
work tua
doesn't complain about getting benched
fitzpatrick doesn't complain about not
being the starter when he's the one
who's saving the bacon
no one in the locker room is talking on
or off the record about any disagreement
with anything that's happening
brian flores has full and complete
control of this team controls the
message
makes the decisions i don't think this
is sustainable into next year
but they found the right balance and
it's working and that's a testament to
flores
yeah i did my tentative ballot mic i
just like to do it the week before
and then take a look at it during the
week and then make your final decisions
after
sunday and i was sitting there going boy
the ron rivera story if washington wins
is so great but
how do you deny what flores has done
when you think about where this team was
how bad they were a year and a half ago
tank for tua all this stuff
and look at how it's worked out and the
ability to manage the team
through all this mickey fitzpatrick and
all pro safety traded out the door
playing well against for pittsburgh you
may see him in the playoffs
yet they're still performing at every
level in this miami team
can i just ask you a quick question
and brian floyd is probably his number
two guy but i just don't think
and how could he become number you know
ahead of um
kevin stefanski kevin stefanski i mean
you look at what
their the browns were last year i mean
they were a total
disaster we never thought they would
even have an opportunity this year
to make the playoffs and the job that
he's done and he's been quiet he's been
humble
but he's just been a football coach and
as much as brian flores and i was with
him
in new england i admire what he's
accomplished
but kevin stefanski hands down for
everything that he had to deal with
this year and turn around and and to
change a culture
so quickly in the nfl locker room to me
he's just done an outstanding job and i
think he should be coach of the year
just my my humble opinion
it's a great point i i was making a
legitimate argument for about five
different guys tony go ahead
i love what kevin has done changing the
culture there i think he's been great
but i go back to your point mike
at this time last year a year ago so you
take in a year and a half
laramie tunsil he's gone now our best
offensive player
making fitzpatrick our best defensive
player um
and and people are saying gosh does
anybody want to be there and what is our
front office doing and brian just kept
saying
we have a plan we know what we're doing
and people have bought into it
and i think ryan fitzpatrick's interview
after the game when they were trying to
bait him into saying
i want to start and i should be the
starter and he says you know what
coach flores is going to make that
decision and whatever he decides is
going to be the right decision
and we are all on board with it i
thought that that was a treme
it just warmed my heart to hear him say
that
what about cole you said coco
yeah i know you know you split your vote
it's tough to kind of split your vote
and it's odd because you only vote for
first place
it's a conversation we'll get into next
week but like the mvp vote when you have
an mvp vote
you only get first place it's the only
major sports mvp where you can't go
first second
third i wish you could go for a second
there because now you're asking people
to pick
between aaron rodgers and patrick
mahomes really
how how do you you can say ones first
but you want to have somewhere on your
ballot so
when all that conversation came up in
october you know russell wilson's never
received it
even one vote for mvp there's a reason
because in all the years that he had a
chance to be the mvp
for most there was a clear-cut number
one choice so that was a
silly conversation all right can i ask
you guys real quick who's going to be
out in the afc who's not going to make
it
which team will be left on the outside
oh hang on rodney
i i don't i know it's a tough question
it's not that hard it's okay
then i'll start you're a little
flustered so i'm going to come to you
who's the team that's going to be out in
the afc rodney
i i hate to say it but i think it's the
indianapolis coast i just
i just think that pittsburgh and balt i
mean not baltimore but whose other team
the buffalo bills will rest their
players and i just think you know
the the indianapolis coast had an
opportunity they stopped running the
ball the defense couldn't stop anybody
in the second half and i think
unfortunately they've had an outstanding
year i think they're going to be on outs
tony well i'm going to go the opposite
i'm going to say the miami dolphins
i think that number two seed is very
important to buffalo i think they want
to play
at home against pittsburgh if it comes
down to that
and as rodney you remind me over and
over again i've taken warm weather teams
up there
in december and we have shivered
and not played our best and i can see
miami going up there with all good
intentions and going to buffalo and 10
degrees
and not playing their best indianapolis
is going to beat jacksonville so
uh i think it's going to be miami all
right mike
and i agree with coach i think it's
going to be miami because i think the
bills are going to win that game but if
the bills pull their starters and miami
wins
you know all these teams at 10 and 6
could win it would be the colts at 11
and five that don't make it who would
have dreamed that a team doesn't make it
at 11 and five with seven spots
available
but uh and and then in the nfc you could
have a team at eight and eight that gets
in so
uh that's gonna happen every year but it
would be bad for the colts
well not eight that's a wild card
i mean it's a wild card okay six and ten
you can have a team get into six and ten
if the giants end up pulling it off
that's what i'm thinking can you imagine
if you're indianapolis
and you're 11 and 5 and everybody wins
and you're out of the playoffs
and then you turn on the tv next weekend
and a team that won
five fewer games than you six and ten is
in the postseason that's going to be
hard to stomach
and by the way we've said it once we'll
say it a thousand times we cannot let
these six and ten teams host playoff
games
if there's more than a two game
difference the other team has to host
a tampa in all likelihood we'll be going
to a six and ten
or a seven to nine win team i know you
won the for commissioner
home playoff game no no i'm good thank
you i'll take the salary
but i'm good with everything else let me
ask you guys about the rams arizona game
for a second because
you look at this and all of a sudden
you're going to see john wolford playing
quarterback tony
week 17 and you have to go with a
quarterback who has never thrown a pass
in the nfl
how does sean mcvay tackle this one
you go chuck noll he was in that
situation mike
florio will remember it well in 1974 and
he said we're going to run the ball
and play defense and that's what you
have to do and if the
game comes down to that if kyler murray
is limited
or can't go then arizona be in the same
boat and i would put a little more stock
in in uh la at that point if it comes
down to two teams
running the ball and playing defense but
i think that's what it's going to be
yeah if you're the rams defensively you
have to just try to
try to figure out a way to come up with
a couple um turnovers try to score on
defense aaron donald those guys
jaylen ramsey they're gonna have to just
step up and play you know your offense
is down you don't have your starting
quarterback you're missing two of your
your running backs um you're gonna have
to score on
on the defensive side of the ball and
look john wilford is on that team for a
reason they could have brought back
blake bortles they could have signed
some other quarterback if they wanted to
they went with john wilford he's been
there all
year he knows the offense sean mcveigh
believes in him and
if we believe that mcvea is the genius
that he has proven to be
we got to defer to his choice at
quarterback at backup quarterback and i
think that walford
as that guy that mcveigh has taught and
instructed and is guiding through you
know the the
speaker in his helmet every play what to
do and how to do it
i think the rams will be fine and and
here's the problem for the rams
if they're fine with john walford you're
going to have more and more people
saying why did you give all that money
to jared goff
yes you will be the arizona hot shot go
out and win and he does it well
that's right what do you do for the
playoff game the next week the arizona
hot shots have never gotten more
attention and love than they have
this past week it's funny guys i was
looking back at a wake forest notre dame
game that
we did three years ago and the two
quarterbacks at wake forest
were wolford the starter and kendall
hitting the back up and hinton's the one
who played
for the broncos with their quarterback
who would have known that the wake
forest one and two quarterbacks would
become a significant part
that's how crazy this nfl season has
been chicago
rodney we laughed on the set who would
have thought you say chicago's got one
of the hot offenses and all the nfl
right now
they're playing green bay they're
playing a much better team than they
have the last four weeks
this week can they ride that momentum at
soldier field and get themselves into
the playoffs
no no the green bay green bay wants that
number one seed
they want the number one seed i mean if
you're aaron rodgers
you're 40 something years old man you
want that number one seed you don't work
this hard to get to the point
in week 17 you're playing against the
chicago bears and you lose to the
chicago bears that's just not going to
happen i don't see that happening
that that buy is so important like i
said before like i said early in the
show it feels like an eternity because
now your body's recovered your mind and
you're ready to play so i don't see
aaron rodgers losing
to the chicago bears i don't care what
type of momentum they have
aaron will drive these guys but rodney
they still are going to have to overcome
human nature we just killed this team by
15 points we they're they're not as good
as we are
and um green bay is going to have to
overcome that chicago is better than
when
we saw them on sunday night green bay is
very good green bay should win it
but there's that just emotional effect
that hey you know
we can handle these guys we're going to
be fine
you know even though the hackers are 25
and go ahead rodney
no i'm just saying it even though the
packers
go ahead mike even though the packers
are 25 and six
under matt laflore and he's a guy that
could be on that ballot as well for
coach of the year we just take for
granted
that he's going to make this team 13 and
3. um they
have the potential out of the blue
to have one of these games where
everyone's scratching their heads saying
what happened to the packers today
where was their energy what went on and
you'll hear aaron rodgers talk about it
after the game i don't know what
happened
and and i'm always watching for that
next i don't know what happened game
from the green bay packers so i can
never rule it out
and and coach like you said they beat
the bears easily the last time around
this could be one of those pothole games
for the packers and the next thing you
know they don't have the top seed i'd
like to think that what they did in the
snow to the titans will be all the
incentive they need
to go to soldier field take care of
business so the road to the super bowl
goes through lambeau field
are you guys nuts are you guys nuts so
all of a sudden because
they beat the chicago bears earlier this
year and
they beat them you know convincingly now
all of a sudden they're going to get to
week 17
with the number one seed on the line and
all of it all of a sudden they're going
to say you know what
we're complacent we're not going to go
these guys are hungry
aaron rodgers devonte adams these guys
are hungry now you adding aj dylan in
the mix
it just and he's gonna be a great
compliment to aaron jones i think you
guys are just flat out wrong this is a
very mature team
and aaron rodgers knows that his window
of opportunity is closing
that's why he keeps talking about these
mvps and how important they are
i just i don't i believe that this is a
very mature team they got great
leadership and i just believe that
they're going to come out and they're
going to give it to the chicago beers
there are still the scenarios where
chicago gets in the playoffs
if they lose this game which is probably
the most likely scenario
if that's the case what a fascinating
week or two of conversation that will be
around the bears because they got in the
playoffs they rallied from a very
poor record to get in and the question
mike floyer is going to be what do you
do now with
all the decisions that have to be made
regarding gm head coach and quarterback
if this is in fact a playoff team which
they very well could be even if they
lose to green bay
and i think they've done enough to keep
ryan pace at gm and matt nagy at head
coach for another season
i still wonder why ted phillips name is
the president of the team doesn't come
up more often he's been there 20 years
he's the one common link
through the under achievement the team
has had for the most part
but trubisky is going to be the key
because they didn't exercise the fifth
year option
he's headed for free agency and if they
play in january and other teams get a
chance to see him and he plays well
that's when
that's when that market could start to
bubble up for his services and the bears
could end up having to pay more than
they want to pay to keep him around
or or rip up the uh the roster at the at
least at the quarterback position and
start over again next year
all right so who's out arizona the rams
of chicago
i think arizona's gonna be out i think
they're gonna struggle with kylo and
murray being limited playing against
that defense
i think they're gonna struggle i agree
with you coach i agree with columbus
yeah i think it's gonna be arizona it
may be chris strebler chris stravaler
cfl
legend dual threat quarterback he's not
a very good passer
chris dreveler at quarterback
potentially but i just arizona
gave us a glimpse of what they could be
but they've kind of regressed to this
500 level team
and and i fear that that's all they're
going to be without some sort of a
major upgrade maybe defensively maybe
change things up offensively use kyle
murray a little bit differently but
i they they they disappointed me the
most for as good as the bills have been
since the hail murray game
the cardinals are the ones that went the
other way
don't doubt the nfc the conference of
championship quarterbacks
rogers breeze brady
wilson and stridler one's won the grey
cup right
championship quarterbacks reside in the
nfc so don't count them out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports